This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology.
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, on listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Starting a business during this decade, starting a successful business in this decade is a big goal that I know a lot of you guys have. I so often get requests for advice on this or to bring somebody on who can give us some no bullshit, straight shooting advice on what it takes, how to formulate an idea, how to execute an idea, how to handle money, investment stuff. Today I am so lucky to have that somebody on the podcast who can talk us through all of these things.
Brittany Saunders is the founder and CEO of Fate the label. It is an iconic Australian clothing brand, iconic. that has exploded in recent years and she started this business in her 20s. I'm so excited to have her on and to hear her story. Brittany Saunders, welcome to the psychology of your 20s. Thanks for having me, Gemma. I feel like your voice is so calming. Do people say that to you?
They do, they do. I don't know what it is, though, because I find my voice really irritating. But I feel like I need to match the way that you talk so that we can. No, I'm not going to do that. Because my voice is like naturally very loud and then you're being really calm. So I'm like, I think I need to be calm. Yeah, I hear it funny. Well, I was saying, look, I love having to you before this.
I was like, I love having another Australian on the podcast. I feel like you need to get some more on. I know, I do. I do. I do a lot, but like just this year, I just haven't happened. That's kind of cool, though, if you're mixing it up and getting people from all over the world. But I feel like people always say, oh my God, yeah, like you don't have a strong Australian accent. And I'm like, I think I do.
But hearing your accent. Mine's pretty strong. Yeah, and I love it. I'm like, oh, maybe I should really, maybe I should get back to my roots. Yeah, how the fuck I am. I really get into it, you know, like really put us. We can talk like that the rest of the episode. And everybody turns it off.
And the downloads are gone. Yeah. Okay, well, tell me a little bit about your story. I feel like I'm going to get ahead of myself. What did you want to be when you grew up? Where did you grow up? What's like the history of Brit? So I am from Newcastle, which if you're not familiar or anyone listening,
it's a little regional city two hours north of Sydney, or maybe two and a half, depending on what part of Sydney you're coming from. is massive. So I'm a born and bred newie gal. I lived like around Australia in my late teens and early 20s. And a long story short is in high school, I discovered this website called YouTube and I thought that looks fun. So I just started that as a hobby and did it all throughout high school. I dropped out of school when I was 16 to be a waitress because I hated being at school. I had no interest in school. I wasn't bad in school. Like, I was actually pretty good and especially like in year 10, like at the subjects that I chose. But I just like had no interest
in being there. And I feel like from a young age, like when you're a teenager, you're kind of told by all of your teachers and the careers advisor, you know, you've got to figure out what it is that you want to do for the rest of your life right now. And it's like, I am 15. I don't even have a lobe to develop. Like, it's not there. I just so vividly remember being in like year nine and going into year 10. And I was a year young for my year as well. So I was going into year 10 and, you know, you'd have, like we got introduced to the school
careers advisor. Yeah. And they used to make you do this quiz. Did you do this quiz? Like this, it was like 10 pages and it was like, what are you going to be when you grow up? Yeah. And it's like, how do I know? And I remember back then thinking, I have no idea what I want to do.
like I had no idea. I had no interest in the idea of going to uni. And I remember all my friends in school at the time, like they knew that they were going to go to uni and become a nurse because their mum was a nurse or whatever. Or they want to be a teacher. And I remember going to the careers advisor and thinking and saying, I don't know what it is that I want to do. And something really random. At one point, he was trying to sell the idea to me of going into the Army Reserves. Oh my God, I just got chills because that happened to me as well. Did it? I genuinely just got chills.
I'm not even joking. You got goosebumps. I got goosebumps because that happened to me. They were like, you should really join the Army Reservoir. And I was like, what part of me makes you think that that's a good idea? I know. I'm not this young girl. Like, no clue.
And I don't know if they were like incentivised. Maybe that's what I was just thinking. He had like all brochures and pamphlets and he's handing them all to me and I was like, oh, okay, maybe this is what I want to do. So then I went to some like career day at like the Army Resort. Like at Advert. Like an ad phone or something. Yeah. And so, like, I just had no idea.
I applied for a couple of, like, hair dressing apprenticeships. Because you know how, like, when you get to year 10, everyone's dropping out to go become a beauty therapist or a hairdresser? I was like, yeah, okay, that's what I want to do. That sounds great. Yeah. So I went and did a couple of trials to become a first year apprentice. How many hours did you work when you were doing that?
Just so many, right? Yeah, I think, like, one trial was a week. Unpaid. Unpaid? Yeah, back then. I think you have to get paid. I don't even know. I honestly wouldn't put it past them.
Back then, yeah, I remember I got paid nothing. And all I did was sweep floors and make cups of tea for a week at this one place. Then they handed me like a big pack of shampoo and conditioner at the end. They said, sorry, you didn't get the job. I'm there like crying. But looking back now, like I'm so glad that never worked out. So, yeah, dropped out when I was just waitressing in Newcastle, was working on my YouTube channel.
I had over 20 different jobs in my teens and into my early 20s and worked in every industry because I was just trying to. to figure out what it was that I wanted to do, doing the YouTube. And then throughout those late teen years, I also dabbled in what I didn't know at the time were businesses. But I just thought that were like little hobbies or something, you know? So I did like mobile spray tans. And then I set up a little spray tan business at home because I had this like lawn mower storage underneath my house. That's very smart. It was like on a sloping block. And then you knew how they'd be like the wooden door and then like a brick room under the back of the house. Yeah, yeah, yeah. This is a very
Australian thing. Yeah. I don't know why. Yeah, I used to always walk past these and be like, there are children trapped in there. Yeah. You know what I mean? I was in there doing pupping little spray tans. So I set up a business there. I would have been 17 or 18 at the time, taught myself how to do makeup and was doing a bit of makeup on YouTube and stuff. So then I was doing freelance makeup. Um, tried decorating and selling iPhone cases on Facebook. There were just so many things that I did in those early developmental years that I just thought were like fun. You know, I never really made any money out of them. And then my YouTube kind of really kicked off. Do you remember the video? It wasn't a video. It's because I'd been doing it for years,
like from ages of 15 up until 21, which is how many years? Six. Like six years. So from, yeah, about 15 years old to 21, I went from zero subscribers to 80,000. And back then, back to the then that was kind of like a big deal. That's still a big deal. Yeah. Back then I remember like the OG YouTube days. Yeah. And so to have 80,000 subscribers was like kind of a big deal and I was 21 and I was working full time in an admin role in Newcastle. And I was just earning like a little bit of money off the ads. And then this is when Instagram had come out as well. So I had maybe 20,000 followers on Instagram. And I started getting paid like $50 for an Instagram post, $100 for an Instagram post. you know, just like holding up a protein powder next to my face or whatever.
Do you remember how, like, how low energy it used to be? Yes, I would. Adds back then? It was like, um, one brand that I worked with back then was protein world. I don't know if you remember that. And they had like this slender shake or some shit. Oh, classic. It was in like the skinny me tea days.
Yeah, I was just thinking that. And I'm pretty sure I did like one of those detox tea post too. And like you would literally get sent the product and I would just hold it next to my face and smile in a selfie and put that on Instagram and I'd get like $150. And so that was like the. I'll do it. Yeah. So that was the start of me, like, earning money through Instagram and obviously making a bit
off the YouTube ads. And, again, long story short, but at the age of 21, I kind of looked at the money that I was earning through my YouTube and Instagram, which was nothing. And I was living in a sharehouse at the time with, like, three other people, paying like $100 a week rent, $60 on petrol, $50 on groceries back then. I remember working out, okay, this is how much it costs me to live. I'm going to quit my full-time job and try to make this YouTube thing, my full-time job. What's the worst that's going to happen?
Yeah. If this doesn't work out, I will just go and get another job because I've had over 20 by this point. Yeah. And I've been working for myself ever since. So it's been 11 years now. Wow. I'm 32 now. And obviously the YouTube then absolutely boomed.
In three years, that 80,000 subscribers I built. to a million and then I was like a full-blown influencer in that first like wave of influences in Australia which was so surreal looking back on now it just doesn't feel real what was the coolest thing you got to do whilst you were because to break the fourth wall like I was how much younger than you're I'm seven years younger yeah so I remember being in high school so you were a little teenager I was a teenager and I knew who you were yeah you were like this is the you were like the one of like the it girls yeah like the Aussie girls but like the Bogan one oh well because that was in the era of like beauty guru and i know there's all these others like um there was that girl
los curtis cloy more yes oh my gosh sharnie grimmin chloe zep and then there was me going how the fuck are you and then everyone would go she's the bogan one oh my god i just always stayed true to myself yeah you totally did um the most surreal thing back then probably would have just been all the opportunities of traveling with brands, like getting taken to Spain with Nas Cosmetics for a global brand trip when they were launching a new mascara. Just going all the way to Spain for three days, just for them to launch the red climax mascara. Which, by the way, but that's kind of iconic.
Yeah. I have that mascara. Yes, I still have it. We went to the launch of that. You know what? This is just this whole economy where people think that like influencing and like content creation is like that's not a real job. It's like no, no, no.
Like the money behind these industries is billions and billions and billions of dollars. Yeah, exactly right. And it's changed a lot since back then when I did all of that. Like the industry as a whole is completely different. And I guess back then we were lucky because what we were doing was aspirational. It was like, oh my God, did you see Brittany got to go on the trip and with Tart trips, you know, to Hayman Island? Oh my God, I remember those.
The tart trips. It was like, cool, because it was new, and it was this whole new era of influencing. And then influences got picked, and then everyone was almost like excited. Like, oh, this is so cool. Whereas it's been so interesting now to have been around for so long where a brand will do a brand trip now. And people go, this is tone deaf. You know, like they're sick of it. They're like, this is too on a, did you see this thing the other day?
It was like having a life core where it's like, I saw this post about this the other day where it's like, we don't want unattainable things. Like people are moving back to like the authentic. Yeah. Like content of like this is unattainable. Yeah. People love to see just everyday life. People go into work and then documenting that.
But I guess I feel lucky that I was in that kind of first wave of influences in Australia because it was new and it was cool. And everyone was like, oh my God, this is amazing goals. Okay. So this is this like amazing journey. You've been on a fun journey. Like when did you decide to quit influencers? and when did you first get the idea for fate?
So the idea of fate came about probably around the age of 23 to 24 and people will always look at fate now and go, oh, like what was your business plan? Like you must have had, you know, all of your ducks in a road to like looking at what fate is today. But I always say when I started fate, it was much like when I started the spray tans under my house. It was not this big grand plan.
I dabbled in lots of other small little businesses. I think the only difference with fate and going into the world of e-com was I was a little bit older. I was still very young. But I also had an audience. Yeah. So I knew obviously, well, I've got all these people following me. I've got these YouTube subscribers of over a million.
I've got potential customers here. So that was the biggest difference for me. And it was definitely an advantage. But that doesn't mean that I, I knew how to run a business. It didn't mean that I knew how to build one from scratch or scale one or sustain it, but I had that audience. And it was very much a, I'm like a very think of it and do it person.
Like I'll lay in bed at night and then have an idea pop into my head and I'll go, AJ, I've got this idea. And then I'll start doing it tomorrow. It was very much the same when it came to fate. It was just learning everything myself. And I think like I had the experience of working with so many, I work with so many brands, like in my early 20s. I had ongoing partnerships where brands were paying me every month to do, you know,
a post for their products and stories. And so I guess I kind of thought in the back of my mind, why don't I do this but with my own products instead of just always promoting other products. And when I was influencing, I even think back to, you know, when YouTubers would do like a Q&A video. Yes. And it'd be like, send me in your questions and I'll do a Q&A. And then you'd be like, hi, guys, welcome back.
I'm going to do a Q&A and then you would get like thousands of comments asking questions. And I remember one common question that I would always get back then was what would you do if you didn't have this YouTube stuff? Like that would always be a question that would come up in my Q&As. And I would always say, and I could probably go back and find one of my old videos, they're all archived, but I would always say, I know that I'm not going to do this forever. I knew that it wasn't sustainable for me to be an influencer forever. I mean, I definitely could. I could still be, you know, a full-blown influencer now, just doing brand deals every day.
But like even back then, like when I was in the peak of the YouTube stuff and like the influencer sponsored posts, like I always knew in the back of my mind, I don't want to do this forever. I felt like I had more that I wanted to achieve or do. I just didn't know what it was. And so when it come to me launching fate, it wasn't this big grand idea. I didn't think I'm going to turn this into a really popular brand and we're going to have all of these sizes. It was very much, I'm just going to start this thing. I hired AJ, who's my partner, his mom's family friend's daughter, to just come and work with me because it was just at my house.
Yeah. So I was like, yeah, just come and work with me like two to three days a week and just help me pack the orders and do the customer service and go to the PO box. to get our returns. And so it was very DIY. And AJ, he was an electrician at the time. So he would just, he helped me like set everything up and like, oh, his post accounts and website. I just learned how to build a Shopify website. It was just very DIY. And I didn't see past that moment when I started it. Do you think that was helpful? Yeah. Just to be like, we're just going to make this now? Yeah, 100%. And I think, again, much like how I started my influencer journey, really early. I'm also glad that I started Fate eight years ago because I didn't have all these
expectations that maybe someone starting a business now would have because I could imagine it would be really overwhelming for, let's say, someone's wanting to get into e-com and start a little Shopify store. This episode is not sponsored by Shopify. I know, I can't. No, but they're just really good. Yeah. We use Shopify for Fate. Yeah. Um, you know, if I was starting today and I, like, when I started Fade, this was before like small business. TikTok. Like there's no such thing as that, you know, people, no one was creating content about their business. And I even remember back then when I started Fate thinking, oh, like, I don't know if I'm going to be able to put this like on my social media because I don't know if my
audience will like this because they want me to do Kmart Hall and vlog, you know, going shopping at West. Yeah, Q&A. And so I started posting a couple little YouTube videos about it. And I would never show my shed at home because that's where it was set up first. But I would go upstairs into my spare room. But this is my HQ and office. But then I would never show the garage because I was embarrassed of it. Whereas now, like in 2025 or 2026, if you were starting a business in your garage, you document the shit out of that.
But maybe that's like why it's so hard these days because it's like you have to get over this. It just feels like everything has to be public. So all the things have to be perceived. So if it's not looking great, not looking perfect, if it fails, it's like it's just so visible. But back then, because no one else was doing that, I was like, oh, I'm not going to show this. People aren't going to take me seriously. But if I could have my time over, or if I was starting now and I was still starting in my spare bedroom and all the plastic tubs in my shed, I would 100% document that because people love to see that
behind the scenes. They do. And again, long story short, fate just grew over those first few years and we moved out, got our first little warehouse in Newcastle hired employee number two employee number three then we had a little team in 2019 we opened our first store and that's a whole other story as well but the only reason that we opened our first store was because we had to move again because we were growing and the building that we got had a little showroom downstairs oh cool you're like let's do it yeah so that was 2019 just before COVID again I had no idea how to run a store but I would just get on Google again
this is before chat GPT or anything so I was just Googling this stuff. And I just remember Googling like, what's a good point of sales system like to have in Australia, you know, how to get shopping bags made? Like I'm just Googling everything. Again, hide like people I knew, family, friends or whatever. And like I just worked in the shop myself most of the time when we first opened. And when I opened that store, I had no intentions of ever opening another one. It's just been like this natural snowball effect over the eight years of fate that it's gotten us to where we are today. But it all started from me, just going, yeah, I'm going to give this thing a go. And just like the one foot in front of the next kind of
mentality. Exactly. And the more that you do things that obviously scare the crap out of you, like I remember when I thought, okay, we're outgrowing my little double garage at home. I think I need to get a commercial lease. So much of money. Yeah, it was, I was looking around and the one that we got, it was like 100 square meters, like quite small. And I think the rent was like $35,000 a year. And I just remember thinking, well, I've got my one employee. I'm having to pay her casual. And then I'm going to have to pay $35,000 a year. What if we don't make money or what if people just stop buying from us, you know, but you take that risk, even though it scares the crap out of you, then you move in, you go, oh my God, like this is working. Then you move on to the next step.
And it's not until you actually make those decisions and take those risks that you'll soon realize great things can happen if you just take that step. Oh, yeah. We need to take a break here. I'm going to get over my head with questions if I don't take a break now. So we're going to take a break here. And then I want to talk about this feeling of like, you know when the time is right. What were some of the mistakes you made?
What are some of the things Google didn't teach you? So stick around. We'll be right back. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of Congress. crack.
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking.
Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice of. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man.
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Speaking of Google and speaking of like a very DIY, intuitive gut kind of approach, what's something that you could never have Googled, that you learned in like the first two years of building fate? Everything.
Everything. Business is just making mistakes constantly and learning better for next time. You're never going to be perfect at any of it. Like you just always, it's like a self-improvement journey, owning a business. But some things in particular that Google couldn't have prepared me for. One of the main things would be probably the emotional journey of going on a business, going on a business, starting a business, you know what I mean? And also how much starting a business isn't about you at all.
Because when we start a business, it is kind of selfish, right? Because you're like, I want to start this for me, because I have worked in over 20 jobs and I hated them all and I want to start this for me. but if you actually want to start a business and you want to turn it into something, it's eventually going to involve other people. And when you own a business and you have staff, it's no longer about you anymore. And looking at my business now, people would probably see like our fate social media and my social media. And it probably just looks like the Britney show because I'm like the face of the brand and whatever. But in my day-to-day life, when I'm at work from Monday to Friday in the office,
it is not about me at all. It's about everyone else. And I think that's something that Google couldn't have taught me. You learn as you go from, you know, people management, dealing with people's wants, needs, emotions, their personal lives and things that they bring into work from the outside, just learning to manage people. I didn't have one day of experience as even a team leader in any of the jobs that I had.
So I think it's like the people and emotional side of business that Google definitely couldn't have prepared me for. What was like the most costly mistake that you made in like the early days? Do you remember having a moment where you were like, oh, my God, we cannot make that mistake again? Yes, I definitely have an answer for this. But at the time, it wasn't an expensive mistake. But if I could do my time over again, I would have done it differently. And that would be hiring the right people at the beginning of my business.
Yes. When we start a business, especially when it's small and it was just at home for me at the beginning, my. And because I wasn't taking it seriously because I didn't have this big business plan. It was easy for me back then to go, I'm just going to hire all my friends, all my friends's friends and all my family friends. I do. I've done this. I feel like every business owner does. You want to help.
It's just a thing of like, who do I trust the most? Exactly right. And you think, oh, this is going to be fun. Yeah. You know, because you're not serious about your business. You just want it to be fine. Yeah, I'll work with my best friend and my cousin and this and that and the other. Sister, yeah, all these things.
And at the beginning of any business, it's fine for it to be that way. And, you know, some businesses are family run or friends together and it works. But for me, personally, one of the biggest discoveries for me, probably for the first three years. I always like to say that the first three years of a business is like a trial. And then after three years, that's when it turned into a real business. Okay, yeah. But yeah, for the first three years of fate, it was pretty unsurious. It was a lot of fun.
I was best friends with everyone that I employed. We were all hanging out outside of work and drinking on the weekends and going to each other's house and all that kind of stuff. And then as the business grew, I realized I can't have this like mix of personal friendships and relationships in a business because the lines just become. Everything becomes a personal insult, every piece of feedback. And you hesitate to say things that you really should. That's because you care about them. avoiding hard conversations was another big one of mine in those early years because, yeah, we're naturally people pleases. We don't want to upset anyone. And then if we're besties with someone that's also working for us and they kind of do something wrong or they've slacked
off, you don't want to go, hey, like I just noticed that you're dropping off in your work performance because then you're worried. They're going, what are you talking about? Like, you know, because you're friends. And so I would say looking back, if I could do my journey all over again, I wouldn't redo it, you know, at any point. But I guess if I was starting today, one of the biggest lessons that I've learned in my business journey, and it's great advice for any business owner out there, it doesn't matter how far you are into your journey is, it's cliche, but people will either make or break your business.
And if you're serious about your business, which I wasn't at the start, not many people are because you just don't think big picture, I would hire the right people that are serious about my business and not take the easy route of just hiring friends and family. But, you know, I have no regrets and it worked at the time. Yeah. But on reflection now and looking where we are in 2025 where I've just got a team full of A players who are so serious about fate and their careers and they want growth and progression and I'm watching them build careers right before my eyes. I'm like, oh, I should have done this from the beginning. But I don't think you can. I think you've got to go through all the motions and again, like learn from your mistakes so that you can do
better in the future. Yeah, I like what you said. I think what you're really saying is like if you had the option or if somebody listening to has a fledgling business and has the option, take the option of hiring somebody you don't, you don't know. Exactly. Yeah. Somebody who is coming in as an employee, full stop, nothing else. Exactly right. And also hiring people that are better than you. Yeah. That's another one. again, like all business owners, and I don't want anyone to think that what I'm saying is wrong, but for the first four years of fate, I was so fine with hiring people that had no experience at all and teaching them everything that I knew because I had taught myself how to do every part of
the business from packing orders to doing our email campaigns in Canva and building Shopify and doing products and all this kind of stuff. So for those first four years, I would always just hire someone that was nice and friendly and that I got along with. But another lesson for me, and especially like in the most recent years, is it sure, it might cost more to hire someone who comes with a wealth of experience. And as a business owner, you know, that can be scary to have someone who's wanting a higher pay based on their experience. But it's priceless to have someone come in who knows their shit and knows what they can do for the business. Rather than bringing someone in and sure, you might not have to pay them as much because they've got no experience,
but then how much time are you spending, teaching that person everything and double checking everything. So that's probably another one of mine is hiring the right people and not being afraid to hire people who are better than you at certain things. So they can come in and own their space rather than you being a helicopter boss trying to make sure, you know, the email looks right before it goes out and the Instagram stories are all good, just all those little things. They can just do it. Yeah. Yeah. What does a typical day in your life look like nowadays? And you kind of gave us an insight, but you used to, you know, the history of Britain, it's like you used to be really prominent on social media and you were mainly influencing and now you're running this business. And like, what does that mean? You know when people always like, oh, you run a business, what do you do on a day to day?
Yeah. Clit, but no two days are the same. I gave up influencing. I want to say two or three years ago now. Did you make an announcement or were you just like... It was very gradual over the years. I went from doing a sponsored post like every second day on Instagram and I really narrowed it down. And by the end, I think I was only working with two brands that I had ongoing partnerships with. There were Esme skincare. Do you know Esme?
Esme? I don't know the proper way to say it. ESMI. Oh yeah, yeah. You would probably know it if you saw it. Oh yeah. I know. When you said I was like, yeah.
Classic Australian brand. Yes. and Canadian club because I'd work with them a heap of times. That's not what I expected you to say. Yeah. So at the end, they were the two brands that I was left working with. And I'd given up like all the hairstyling tool brands. Like I worked with GHD for a really long time.
All sorts of ones. And I ended up only having the two partnerships. And I sat on the idea for maybe a year or two to also give those up because I had like ongoing partnerships with them. And I went to my accountant and I said, I think I just want to give up this all together because I was like Brittany Lee Saunders as a company and then I had fate. And the great thing about being an influencer was I didn't have to pay myself anything from fate for the first like four years of fate. That was one of my questions.
Yeah, I didn't pay myself for anything. I worked on fate and had my influencing on the side and the influencing was my personal money. And then all the money that the business generated paid my staff and went back into the business. And so, yeah, it would have been two to three, maybe three. three years ago now, I decided I'm going to give up the brand deals. I'd already given up YouTube by that point. Just because I was getting too busy running the business and I just had to prioritize not spending my time making YouTube videos to grow the business. And then, yeah, I bit the bullet and said I'm not doing any more brand deals. And that was, yeah, three years ago now. I think over
those three years, we've done like two that have like come our way that were like too good to pass up kind of thing. And things you cared about. Yeah. And like maybe two years ago, KFC said, can you please do something for Christmas in July? And they had these funny, ugly sweaters. I was like, yeah, we'll do that one because that's really fun. Yeah. But I've just done a couple over the last three-ish years.
But yeah, I fully gave it up, which just then allowed me, number one, to start paying myself from Fade as an actual employee and getting a pay slip and everything every week. Oh, my God. Yeah, how fun. Yeah, which was really exciting. And then it's just allowed me to fully focus on fate rather than worrying about, oh, I've got to get this post done for so-and-so brand. What my day looks like today, I'm a very hands-on founder and CEO.
I work heavily with our marketing team for all things marketing at fate, whether that's big campaigns that we're doing, any of our customer brand trips that we do, which has been awesome to do, like, off the back of influencing. Explain what these are. The customer brand trips are pretty. iconic for you guys. Yeah, so we've done two now. We started it on our seventh birthday last year to celebrate our seventh birthday. Every year our birthday comes around and the team will go to me, shit, it's our birthday in two weeks. Like we haven't organized anything. And last year, I think we thought
about our birthday like two months before because you don't think about your business as birthday. You got too much going on. And it's in September. So it's like coming up to the busy period. And I was like, well, why don't we take seven customers on a brand trip, kind of like how I used to go on all the brand trips back in the day. But instead of taking influences, let's take customers and like treat them like influencers. And so then that's where the idea of the lucky seven came to be. And we did a big old giveaway and seven random customers won a trip with us. And it was like such a hit and we got so much content out of it and they had the best time and they all made such great friends. We were with them for three days. Where did you go? We brought them to Newcastle. We were like, let's start it at home.
Yeah. Newcastle is also a vibe. Yeah. And we've got like, five-star hotels now. So we put them in... Do you have a five-star hotel in Newcastle? Yeah, we got two, which we never used to have. But Newie's really up and coming. But yeah, they all got their own hotel room and we decked out the bed with all the goodies from all the different brands. It was like a full influencer trip. And so that was such a success that we've done it again just this year in September. And we called it the Fate 8 for our 8th birthday. And last year was a lucky seven. And again, just a giveaway, eight customers. We took them to Port Stevens this time. I don't know
if you know where that is. We got this big, beautiful house. us and it was more of like a retreat vibe. So that's been really cool to be able to do. But yeah, I work heavily with our marketing team. I oversee our leadership team at Fait. One job that would surprise people that I still do in FATE and I don't know if I could ever give it up is I do all of our stock buying and ordering. Oh, really?
Yeah. Oh, cool. So every piece of clothing that comes into our business is my responsibility to order and all of our store stock and buying for all the stores is me. No way. That's like one of the hardest jobs. It's a big job, but I think because I've been doing it since day one, I could do it with my eyes closed.
And because we've grown so gradually, it's been easy for me to learn. Like ordering more stocks. Yeah, and this store needs this and that store needs that. Yeah. And I work with our operations manager on that, but that's like one of my main tasks. I run out ad accounts. Cool. Yeah.
So I love meta and Facebook ads. I do a lot still. as the owner and founder. But I'm definitely getting to the point in my business journey where I am feeling like I need to kind of step away and start being more of a founder rather than getting caught up in what UGC creator hasn't sent their content in. You know what I mean?
Yeah, I do not even. But I am, again, it's something that all founders, if their business grows to a certain size, they will find themselves in that situation where you do get pulled into the day to day. But I'm definitely learning as we're growing. I need to focus on those big picture things rather than what did that customer say in that email, you know?
Best to ignore. Yeah. At least you. Delete. At least. Well, bye. Delete. Just put it in the bin and say it went to spam.
Yeah. But yeah, no two days the same. And I'm still very much involved with the whole business from retail to warehouse and everything in between. But I love it at the end of the day. So I literally haven't worked a day since I started fate. I like that. We're going to take one more break. and then I have three more questions for you.
So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex students.
science that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crows. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
This isn't over until Justice. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So we're talking about you, not replying to emails, maybe.
That's one job I have given up is replying to our customer service emails, which has been nice. Because I feel like it gets to a point where it feels so much more personal when it's your business. Like let's say someone is emailing and they're upset with something. And then if you're reading that, it's like, oh, fuck. Anytime I get a bad review. I know, it hurts. It really does. It really stinks.
No, we've got people that reply to those, which is great. I don't. I just don't reply to them. Looking towards the future, what are you planning next? Do you think that you will launch another business? Yeah. Oh my God, cool. I would love to.
What do you think it would be? And if you have, have you had an idea recently where you're like, I don't know if you're like me. I have like a list of my phone of like 20 million business ideas. Sometimes I just give them, I just randomly mention them to people and like you should make that. Yeah, I don't know how to do that, but you should do it. Do you have something like that? There's so many things that I would love to do. It's just a matter of getting around to doing it.
And also I've kind of stitched myself up because Faye's quite a big company. Oh, it's huge. So, yeah, I kind of have got myself tied into Faye. You're like, oh, you're suffering from success. I love it. There's so much that I want to do. I have my business podcast called Big Business, which I absolutely love doing. I feel very drawn to helping others on their business journey,
just based off everything that I've learned. So I love doing my episodes. I do two episodes a week on that podcast, and I just love that. I love making content around business, and I've noticed that people love when I talk about business in like my TikToks and reels and stuff like that. Part of me wants to become like a business coach or a mentor, like maybe in another life, I'll do it or I'll get around to it in this life. You've got a lot more life to live. Yeah, exactly right. And I think as well, like I've been doing a lot of keynote speeches lately.
I just recently did a TEDx talk, which was awesome. What was that like? Really cool. That was just a couple of weekends ago. So I love doing keynotes and talking in front of crowds, whether it's about business or just being inspirational in general, I guess. So I love that. I'd love to do like a tour slash workshop thing of my own one day. but I'd love to do anything and everything.
I had this one idea recently that I made a little video about. A lot of people have said to me over the years that, well, you've had it easy and you've been, you've been lucky because you had an audience online. So, like, of course, you've been able to do what you've done. And I'm like, kind of at the start, yeah, sure, but it takes something completely different to actually grow and scale a business into the size that fate is. Any influencer can launch a product, but, like, not everyone can. can keep it going and then grow it.
And sorry to say this, a product versus how many products do you have right now? So many. You would have at least 150 items for saying, probably more. Yeah. And we've got, you know, five stores, 70 staff. So like it's grown into something bigger than me just being an influencer and being lucky. But off the back of people saying those comments to me, like, oh, it's easy for you because you were an influencer back in the day.
I would almost love to start a faceless business. Interesting. And do that. I think about this is crazy. Like do like an anonymous business? Yes. And never tell anyone. Yeah, never tell anyone and try to make it super popular or even medium size and then
come out and be like, this was me. And none of you knew just to show that I have what it takes on the other side of being the face of a brand. and I'm going to give away my other idea here. I'd love to make Fates competitor. That's crazy that you are so like in the game that you're like, I want to be my own competition now. Yeah, and start like another clothing brand.
With extended sizes and everything. Yeah, do it all and like different to FATE. And you know, I obviously wouldn't use myself or my face, but instead we'd have to, it's an investment. you'd be working with models, creators, influencers, UGC, paid ads and paid media. And I'd love to look like, it would take years. Yeah. But I'd love to build like Fate's competitor and everyone becomes obsessed with this other
new clothing brand that's got all these sizes and everything. Yeah, and you can be more experimental. Yeah. And then it's just me at the end of the day. And then I'm like, surprise, it was me. And then I merge them together. Kate and Fait. It could be your name.
So that's an idea of mine. But I'm open to. anything and I definitely think I will start other businesses in my lifetime. I still feel like I'm just getting started with fate. So there's a lot of exciting things to explore with fate. I never thought that we would get to where we are today. Like I kid you not, I couldn't see past that garage when I first started. Which I think that's like the coolest part of your story. And for people being like, oh, you know, well, you had a platform. You also dropped out of school at 16 years old. Yeah. You didn't have a, do you get a high school diploma when you drop out in year 10?
No. Yeah. Oh no, I think I got my Year 10 certificate. Year 10 certificate. Yeah, I got that, which means nothing. Yeah, but that's like being like turning to someone and being like, well, you, you had a university degrees. Like, that's how you start your business.
Or everyone has a one up or like all your parents. They had a cafe. So you're on your, like everybody has some kind of advantage. Yes. Everybody has good luck, some kind of good luck. Yeah. I truly believe it. The YouTube subscribers, sure, that was an advantage for me.
But also, I built that YouTube channel for years. Yeah. I built that community for. for years. And, you know, I could have launched fate and it could have been good for a year and that it could have flopped. But it's been like the hard work and determination over those eight years and the persistence, you know, I work seven days a week. But I love it. So I never feel like I'm working. But it's that that's gotten to me, like to where I am. Sure, the subscribers helped at the start because I had people placing orders from day one. But scaling is a whole other
all of a ballgame. Yeah. I can only imagine. Yeah. I have one final question for you. Yes. And this is the question that we ask everybody who comes on the podcast. I could sit here for hours, by the way. I know. I honestly, you know, we've been here. You have to get me back for part two. I kind of want to. There's so many questions that I want to ask that I'm like, what was it like to fire your first person? Like, what was it?
Blah, blah, blah. Like so many questions. Handing out first warning letter. Yeah. Never fun. Never fun for anyone. What happens when people copy you, like all that stuff? But I have one final question, which is the question of the podcast. What is one piece of advice you have for people in their 20s or perhaps you're
younger self that has nothing to do with what we talked about today, completely separate. Has nothing to do with anything. I know, you can't talk about business. Can't talk about what you can. But never know. Like trying, if it's about love, if it's about friendship, if it's about. I've got a saying that I absolutely love, but I don't know. You can tell me if this ties into what we've been talking about.
It kind of does, but it can apply to any aspect and element of your life. And the saying is do it scared. Can I say that as my answer? I like it. Yeah, do it scared. Do it scared. I think the number one thing that holds people back from doing anything in life, and this doesn't mean just starting a business.
It could be saying hello to the guy that you keep seeing at the coffee shop, but you're too scared. Or it could be asking your boss for a raise or a promotion. It could be speaking up in a team meeting where you'd normally stay quiet because you're worried that people might judge you. It could be anything. It could be telling a friend of yours that they've been upsetting you lately by things they've been saying, but you don't say anything because you're too scared.
I just love the saying, do it scared. Because it's very easy for us to say, oh, no, I won't do that. Like, I'm too scared. We use that as an excuse to not do whatever the thing is. But I think it's a good mindfulness thought to think, I can still do the thing even with the scared feeling. Being scared shouldn't be someone's reason to not do something. You can just do it and still feel scared at the same time. Yeah.
And trust me, you'll feel. feel a million bucks after you do it no matter what it is. I love that saying. Do it scared. I think it's honestly a beautiful representation for this episode. Okay, I said I had no more questions, but we'll find a question. I have to ask this question. Just because this came to my mind, what is like the favorite thing that you guys are selling
right now? What's your favorite product that you guys have at fake? Ooh. I would say our downtown pants, which don't look at mine today because I've gotten so dirty today. Sydney is a dirty city. Yeah, I've got like sandwich and something else. some black stuff from Australia Post for me. But I would say it's our downtown pants. They are a, they're kind of made of like a blazer material and they're like your stock standard,
like a dressy kind of corporate pant. We have been making our downtown pants for maybe, I want to say three years now or maybe three to four years and they've only gained popularity in the last 12 months. So it's like a style that people have finally realized like these are the best pants ever. We've done them in like 18 different colors. And they've got like a little elastic on the back. So they're really comfortable. And they're just like a pair of pants that you can like wear to work to the office, but then also like fully dress them up with some heels and wear them out at night. So I'd say it's probably our downtown pants. But our best selling category is denim. Yeah, I will say this is this is what you guys are known for your jeans. Yes. The jeans are,
I keep saying iconic. Yeah. We've got a whole new, a whole new denim. range coming out in 2026, which I'm really excited about. I thought our jeans were already really good because we sell so many of them and they have the best reviews ever, but it's about to come out in a whole new level. You know what? I also say this, this is something that's completely, like Levi's jeans. I don't like Levi's jeans and I don't know why I just have to say it. I hate Levi's. There's actually like a massive gap in the market for good denim because when you think of a brand in Australia that is known for their jeans, who is it? Like, probably Levi's or like just jeans.
Yeah. But it's like they do, this is like just such a personal vendetta I have against Levi's jeans. I've never worn a pair of Levi's. Great, don't. Like they only, like they just don't fit. I'll have to give you some of our new jeans when they come out. I think I might just order some.
I already own a pair of your jeans. I actually own two pairs of your jeans. I own like your classic, like straight-liked ones. Billie jeans? Yeah, I think that's what they're called. They're great. I think they're quite. Well, they're about to get a whole lot better.
There's a new version of Billy coming out. Oh. We've done like a whole new range. Yeah, we've done a whole new range inspired by our current jeans, but they're just leveled up. Is this coming from fate or Kate? Imagine if you just, dude, maybe you should just launch a whole denim company. Don't, because that was my idea. Really?
Yeah. Dang. I've even got a name for it. Sorry. I've got a name for it, but we won't say it on the power. No, don't say it because, no, if somebody does their idea better than you, though, you know. Yeah. And, you know, I think there's room for everyone in business.
Totally. I want to create Fade's competitor as a social experiment, but every brand can exist together and there's enough customers out there for everyone. And also, I would love to see in 2026 and beyond more businesses coming together and collaborating. Like, I would love to collaborate with a competitor of ours. I'm saying like competitor in quotes. Because like imagine if there's two women's fashion brands that come together and come out
with a collection together, bringing both audiences together to go, well, now we love both of these brands. Like Beck and Bridge and Faked the label. That's like a cool like extended size like formal range. I would love to collaborate with another brand that would be considered our competitor. Like I'm friends with, you know, women that own fashion labels and like I don't see them as competitors. I'm like, we can learn from each other and vent to each other when we're stressed about something. Like we can all exist together. Like we can all win. And it's honestly the best feeling is when you have your competition becomes your community. Yeah. What people want to be, you to have as competition, but come to your community.
Absolutely. That is a very positive message to finish and actually finish this episode on. You sure you don't have one more question? Oh, I have like several more, but we just don't have time. Let us know, should I come back for part two? Yeah, guys. Drop a comment below if you want Britt to come back for a part two. Where can they find you?
I'll leave a link to fate.com down below, but where else would you like them to find you? On socials, you can just find me, Brittany Saunders. I've got two podcasts. One is called Big Business. And the other one is high scrollers with my bestie Matt, which is just like an absolute piss take. And it's really funny. It's really nice to have that funny, creative outlet. And then we have five stores in Australia.
We've got three in New South Wales, which are in Newcastle where I'm from, Parramatta and Westfield Miranda in Sydney. We've got one in Brisbane, which is in Westfield, Chermside. And then down in Melbourne, we have a boutique in Hawthorne. And that's about it. You can find me on TikTok and all the other stuff. You'll find her. Everywhere. Read my book.
Just do whatever. This woman is busy. You can find her. Yeah, you can find me. Well, thank you again for coming on. As always, if you guys enjoyed this episode, leave a five-star review. If you feel cool to do so, make sure that you are subscribed or following us wherever you are listening to the podcast and follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. We've been doing these really cool announcements for each of our guests.
And as we kind of come to the end of guest month, we've got some cool ones lined up. But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. and we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart
Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once.
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.